what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to do trans athletes have
an unfair advantage trans versus cis
athletes this is especially important to
me because i was a three sport college
athlete
and so it'll be interesting to see what
they have to say before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell the way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
all right let's let's go
trans athletes have an unfair advantage
step forward if you agree
when you first think about like
transgender athletes i guess the first
thing you think about is well
biologically transition usually happens
after puberty right so
if this biologically
male athlete goes through puberty he
gets like better bone structure he has
all these skills that he enhances um at
least muscle he puts on and then he
transitions
um yes your testosterone levels go down
but you're always just gonna have that
like things that you've gone through
like doing puberty that you have after
you've transitioned so i feel like
there's always going to be that
advantage i think it's dependent on the
gender that they are transitioning to
for example trans women do have somewhat
of an advantage biological men are
natural oh yeah sorry i was only
thinking about it from the male to
female but not the female to male point
of view born with higher bone density
and larger lung capacity and a larger
heart and that's not something that can
necessarily be changed with hormones of
course this isn't the same for
trans uh
men athletes for me it's just on average
guys are typically a little bit stronger
a little bit larger a little bit taller
so depending on the sport taller like
literally sorry if you go and hide alone
and this is
why i think
like duh i don't even know why this is
conversation duh they have an unfair
advantage like think about this i'm in
the top one percent of females for
height
one percent so if i go into 100 girls i
will be taller
than 99 of them i'm six foot okay
on top of that like
when i was in club i was short guys
i'm six foot and for my position for
like a d1 category they like girls six
two and higher so i was on the shorter
end at my club
in the top one percent of females
like
around the world
so
men it's like i think 15
of men are over six foot
so that's a huge difference so i was
short competing with women
in the one percent i was short
like imagine if that was 15 like hide
alone actually
it can give them a large advantage when
you're looking at something like that
when it's something like swimming having
that ability to be a little bit larger
larger lung capacity will overall affect
that
can i have the disagree or step forward
[Music]
among
cisgender men and cisgender women there
are
naturally
differences in their anatomy and their
hormonal levels in their
height so it's unfair
so it's unfair period pressure all that
stuff like any cisgender woman compared
to another might have a different body
type
some women are naturally very strong
if you no i'm sorry
i am a strong female guys i dead lift
close to 300 pounds
like
i think last time i checked it i was at
250 but i probably could have kept going
like i probably could have hit like 275.
bench i can bench a plate like i can
literally bench a plate i am on that
strong end of females the average guy
could whoop me when i come like there
are very few men that i'm stronger than
i'm stronger than most females take
the advantage which i think
in most cases is the hormones and if you
compare no
no
no
for the blood work and you're just
looking at that if they're on the same
level in my opinion there just isn't an
advantage because when you grow up
playing sports some people are good at
sports some people aren't the pro
oh my god that's like the worst argument
i've ever heard in my life
all i see with this argument is that
there's a large group of people that no
matter what i do in a sport will always
automatically assume that i have an
advantage but look at you you literally
do
like guys who do you think who do you
think could bench more
i played sports for 12 years okay
i'm not i'm not a noob
like
i'm going to play volleyball overseas
who who do you think bench is more
honestly they're not taking into account
hours that i put into practice hours
that i put into weight lifting to become
a better athlete roller derby is
probably
90 plus percent cis women i get my ass
handed to me
yes i i am tall and i can i can see that
that can be an advantage in some sports
but it doesn't necessarily
guarantee that i have an advantage oh
yeah well but you you have a natural
advantage
you do like i'm not saying you can't
have a natural advantage and work hard
look at michael phelps
he has a natural advantage
but he competes in his category
if you took all of the top female
athletes and put them against the top
male athletes in the olympics who would
win like i don't even have to look at
the stats who would win
you take the top five percent
like a fee of male athletes
take them atop the top put them against
the top one percent of female athlete
who's going to win
10 20 like
it can keep it keeps going what we
usually hear in the like news and like
politics and stuff is about trans women
just because
they're in so much prominence because
they're
they are winning like i can't remember
what her name is right now but she was a
power lifter she is a power lifter i
think she went to tokyo olympics and
she's transgender
and um they're winning wait they let her
in the olympic what
by like a large amount like of weight if
you truly believe that trans women have
a an advantage even with hormones
then that means you truly believe that
trans men have a disadvantage even with
hormones
wait
tran that i believe trans men
yeah
oh i totally do i agree yeah trans men
so that's girls competing in like the
men's category yes i believe that so the
argument that you hear most of the time
is against trans women so does that mean
that you're okay with trans men having
that disadvantage
yeah
i mean look if if trans men want to go
and get their ass kicked go go by all
means
like nobody cares if you take away last
place but people care if you take away
first from people that have trained
their whole lives for something when i
was like going through high school
um
i
wrestled against females i had to
suppress both my hormones in my body and
i was still able to beat the men too
with my leg levels low
like and i cut 15 pounds a week like
that shouldn't that that was crazy
but like that's what i'm saying like the
body is like a show
and what we do every single day in the
practices and
the
like life lessons that we get like
living
40 years on this earth you know we just
try to live life the best we can yeah
trans
athletes should have a separate category
in certain sports
[Music]
i don't want to say that they should be
in a completely different category just
because
socially and legally yes they are
that gender that they transition to and
putting them in another category just
seems
i'm gonna actually end it here
um i don't really know what a solution
is
i i don't have a good solution for you
to be honest that seems like maybe the
best way to do it their own category but
guys
i'm an experienced athlete and as a girl
like i play against guys all the time
there are guys that i i f up okay but if
i get a guy that comes in i'm six foot
right a guy that comes in that's six
five played a couple years in high
school it doesn't matter that i played
through college
okay
he doesn't even he have to be that good
but like there's only so much you can do
when they're a million times bigger and
a million times stronger than you oh my
gosh i'm so glad i was not
actively competing i guess i will be now
but
like growing up this was never an issue
like never a question but let me know in
the comments if you guys think i'm right
or i'm wrong don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time